and the blazer he is out back tweet and they're going to sit him down tonight but he is here obviously to root on his new teammate Carmelo Anthony who will be getting the start for the Blazers let's take a look at the starting lineups presented by Wilsonville Toyota takes advantage of it at the free-throw line pals for the first ball point to the game so the 5 and 9 team against a 4 & 9 squad Melo looking for triple he's got his first point since November 8th of last season puts the Blazers on the board again that's just miscommunication and holidays anything good set up holiday block by from behind by Melo as Jackson Hayes thought it was going to be an easy one instead McConnell and a lead for Portland CJ McCollum their second lead was out of bounds when he made his step-back three so it's only a four-point lead for the Pels Anthony his bid range get is exceptional he's an elite score at bid rain